malgré de canard poilés de girolle
fraîche et risoto en quelques minutes ce
chef cuisinier prépare un plat gourmand
le geste est précis la cuisine tout est
je dirais pas au millimètre près mais il
suffit d'avoir la bonne recette et après
de à force de faire c'est là on apprend
à être plus on fait plus on sait faire
par exemple un
risotto par rapport à la quantité de Rif
faut toujours mettre une fois et demi
d'eau et vous êtes sûr de jamais le
rater Jérôme sver est chef cuisinier
dans un restaurant haut de gamme de
Montin le Bretonneux formé au lycée
hôelier de 50 ans en Yveline il a débuté
comme simple commis il y a 11 ans avant
de gravir tous les échelons ça fait 12
ans que je fais de la cuisine même après
12 ans j'ai toujours des choses à
apprendre je vois que par exemple les
techniques qu' a à l'école par rapport à
maintenant par rapport à mon époque à
moi et sont parfois sont différentes et
même mes apprentis parfois arrivent et
m'expliquent quelque chose que on ne
faisait pas il y a 10 ans que donc ça
c'est vrai que c'est un métier où
toujours on découvre des choses ici dans
ce restaurant on est fier de montrer le
label maître restaurateur un label qui
garantit la fraîcheur des produits et le
fameux fabriqué maison tout arrivrive
directement de fournisseurs qui viennent
de rinchis et tout ce qui est viande et
poissons est préparé par nous-même
directement on forme des apprentis ça
nous permet aussi de leur montrer
comment comment c'est fait et pour eux
plus
tard pouvoir le faire et pour la semaine
du goût l'établissement propose un menu
à